[Music]
big big news in television Jennifer
Lopez is leaving American Idol did you
notice what a miracle reaction yeah Wow
I hope she's not watching right now that
would be a shocker she's going I could
mean they're they're confirming her
choice yeah maybe they are I don't know
no it's being reported that Jennifer
Lopez decided to leave American Idol
because of Steven Tyler's departure
that's what she said yeah yes she said I
don't want to be the only woman judge
[Applause]
what everyone's talking about the
president on the kiss cam you all saw
this present the first lady in the kids
can be to see this Andy yeah yeah yeah
he blew it well no he redeemed himself
right he finally did yeah yeah yeah
I don't you saw this yesterday at a
basketball game president Michelle Obama
were caught off guard by the kiss-cam
yeah meanwhile Mitt Romney was caught
off guard by the show us your tax
returns cam
granted that one is not as much fun yeah
when you're in the auditorium no one
likes the show as your tax return scam
except the people that have the
foresight to bring their tax returns
room there we go yeah let's do the wave
with them yeah interesting fun facts
since becoming Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton has spent over 300 days
out of the country and then amazing
that's a record yeah President Obama
called her travel record inspiring and
Bill Clinton called it 20 years too late
[Music]
now I want to preface this by saying
everybody's ok everybody's fine but
yesterday Katie Holmes car was hit by a
garbage truck
yeah cops are still looking for the
driver of the truck who is described as
Tom Cruise
[Applause]
[Music]
you couldn't see him over the steering
wheel
he's a nice guy I just like that that's
the one area where you can get him yeah
yeah one area we're close in box office
right just edged me out
Yahoo Yahoo's new CEO Marissa Mayer is
six months pregnant
that's a big story yeah yeah apparently
she was able to hide her pregnancy by
only posting it on Yahoo I'm looking for
angry nerds after that guy I think I
think it's only popular with old
prospectors yeah it's been around a
while was founded in 1944 I believe
speaking of high-tech stuff Apple has
announced its going to be unveiling a
new smaller iPad that they say is aimed
at women yeah that's right
yeah not to be outdone Amazon announced
it's going to soon unveil the vibrating
Kindle
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I give that joke to Germany
that's how proud I am who says we don't
make anything good in this country
anyone in a new interview Elton John
said he never announced he was gay
because he assumed it was common
knowledge he was correct this is
interesting I just read this some of the
most popular baby names of the year are
from the HBO show Game of Thrones
yeah which explains the popular new
girl's name gratuitous nudity
[Laughter]
maybe I should give that joke to Germany
and get the vibrating Kindle back